a man who spent much of his adult life
on your television set and is seen every
single Wednesday including tonight on
CBS on SEAL team David Boreanaz good to
see you sir thanks for a few like to
pick you got on I do yeah I mean you
have to protect your quarterback you
should well this one obviously at this
point in particular yes you know every
there's all this talk about him trying
to you know he's got to stay healthy you
know I mean Carson when he came out he
had such a great season and that Rams
game kind of put him under but he was
heading to possibly an end and he was
David he was the MVP of the season yeah
when he was leaping headfirst towards
the gray zone and got caught Valachi
crunched on his knee oh that was kind of
a weird injury because he kind of pushed
off and it was the the power and
acceleration that really kind of jolted
his whole knee was a strange injury I
mean he's got so much strength and I
think everything just got twisted up I
think he just got caught in the wrong
place a long time yeah and and and
obviously Dillard is is a guy who can
play adjacent Peters yeah he's getting
longer in the tooth yeah as he's making
his way towards Canton Ohio I know for
his gold jacket I think it's a great
pick I think how I Roseman you know did
such a great job has been doing such a
great job with the Eagles and you know
it was a position of need and they got
their player that's the player they
wanted and it's interesting that last
year as opposed to their Super Bowl
season when they just kept running one
running back after another after another
they go ahead and take this kid Myles
Sanders out of Penn State I think one
Barkley back you know he comes out has a
great year last year at Penn State and
you know he's got a lot upside in
specially I think he'll fit in well he's
got that kind of you know shady McCoy
kind of aspect to him people are
comparing him right but he's got his own
style and he's quick right and and we
always talk about chips on the shoulder
right core so obviously having as you
mentioned he's se Kwang's back up at
Penn State he had a really good season
in his first year as the starter they're
now twice a year you're gonna be on the
same field at the same game maybe trying
to match each other I'm just that's a
good one yeah I didn't really think
about that yeah that's actually in the
NFC though that's a that's a great
matchup those two will be balling for
two games out of the year are the season
fun it's gonna be a lot of fun the
Giants they really don't have a core
see now this is great I'm sort of I'm
glad that you give voice to what's going
on with the Giants cuz I was saying all
the Eagles fans Redskins fans Cowboys
fans you met TJ Jefferson our social
media or say did he was a bowl of soup
ok man's right so he's he's all excited
cuz he's a big cowboy fan that everybody
like yourself wants to inject the Giants
fans tears directly into your veins you
can't get enough of the misery that
comes out of the drought it's the best
the people from New York I have a lot of
friends and you know when it comes time
to the Sports Talk and the Giants and
the Eagles right or the Cowboys I mean
even the Redskins it's just that it
brings out the worst in all of us you
know it's dealing with Boston fans and
Philly fans they just go at it but yeah
I mean look the Giants picked somebody
from Duke they did all right and I guess
he'll be good in a few I mean he was
coached by Eli Manning's yeah David
Crane is anning whisperer and that's the
idea right that is that he's the Peyton
Manning Whisperer from back in Tennessee
and obviously he wasn't an Ole Miss but
has been at the Manning passing Academy
forever ever and nothing to take away
from a knee won a Super Bowl I I do too
you want you want to okay I mean you
know sorry
I do think you should be in the Hall of
Fame I think he's a really good
quarterback
I mean he's proven himself but times
over let's see where's the but there it
is time is now for the Eagles and whence
and I'm I'm excited about what Carson
Wentz has to do even if Carson doesn't
lead the Eagles let's say to the
playoffs this year let's say that
doesn't happen
am i that guy that's gonna say we should
have taken folds over and wince no
you're not cuz he's a young player you
gotta let these guys develop feel the
offense they he's got more weapons now
this white sidle kid they picked up
maybe Aguilar is gone I don't know but
he's a big L Sean Jeffrey kind of target
down in the ends in the red zone he can
leap for the ball so you know he's got
targets and he's got weapons now he does
hold on a second David Boreanaz let me
let me let me ask you this then okay
what
if they don't make the playoffs because
whence gets hurt again now now on a
second that's two years in a row II
couldn't finish
so I'm seriously and there's and there's
no foals safety net now it's now it's
then and now it's the Nate Sud Feld
situation by the way great band great
band from back in the seventies the Nate
said Feld situation so I like Nate said
Phil I think I know that but I'm all I
don't know if he's got the foals magic
carpet ride would you still be saying
yes we made the right maneuver yes I'm
sticking to the guy that I love whence
he's he's my guy I'm gonna stick with
him as an Eagles fan I'm going straight
in with him I love what foals did for us
we did for the city of Philadelphia you
know he came in in a strange situation
went goes down like you said he's going
to the MVP year and he starts winning
games we didn't think that we would go
to eight to the Super Bowl with Nick
Foles and then was this miracle run but
that team was special we had a great
defense I mean we we had a lot of pieces
in place at that time that helped propel
us to that Super Bowl win so loving the
Patriot let me throw a name out at you
if somebody who says if whence doesn't
do it in the next two or three years
they should move in a different
direction it his name his name is
Donovan McNabb only that's that's been
this whole controversy with Donovan
McNabb like I know just a little bit
he's saying that what he should move on
no we're not moving on that's not gonna
happen I don't think so either
I just don't I think that's just was it
Lane Johnson who tweeted out about yes
it was right Lane Johnson was upset he's
like that's my quarterback which was
kind of echoing what Terrell Owens yes
right in Balboni about Tony Romo so
right you know look they these jabs back
and forth
I think Donovan McNabb is wrong to say
something like that I mean maybe he's a
little bitter over the fact that he
didn't you know he threw up right before
he was about to well I mean yeah I mean
we saw the whole we kind of saw what
kind of projectile vomiting can v 5-yard
line and in case you didn't see it
tío made sure everybody knew about it
that's one of my most wild memories of
being an NFL Network host right was we
went from Jacksonville which is where
the Super Bowl took place yep
that you're referring to at the Patriots
in McNabb and teo who was heroic to say
the least comin back on that ankle we
went from there to the Pro Bowl okay I
took about three flights to get there
but we got there and when we got there
the NFL Network we had a set on the
beach okay Hawaii we had a few set
possessions I think Provo we had one on
the beach
underneath this this this Tiki umbrella
if you will anyway long story short is
we had all these guests come out and be
interviewed on the beach yeah and we had
McNab and T Oh were both in the Pro Bowl
we had them set up to be interviewed
together and we were told half hour
before they will not appear together Wow
so that was big and where we were all
like because again this is it hadn't
really gotten it hadn't been spun out of
control all right okay this prior to
rioting just kind of yes it ups and push
ups on the lawn and all that Mike this
is when we're kind of looking at each
other like these got what hold on a
second they just played in the Super
Bowl awkward was the first indication we
all got so I interviewed them both
separately okay I both appeared but just
wouldn't do it together did they talk in
passing or no that I don't know NAB
showing up later this month in our
studio booked
I can't wait to ask him all of these
questions you're gonna get the answers
man and I'm sure he's gonna clarify
himself from what he meant when he said
that yes whence is our quarterback I
love the guy I think he's a great
athlete you know Donovan McNabb was a
great quarterback came out of Syracuse
loved what he did for the city of
Philadelphia but you know you just keep
your mouth shut man carry on you know
whence is the guy now let him do his
thing
we've got David Boreanaz here on the
Rich Eisen show seal team tonight at
10:00 p.m. Eastern Time and every
Wednesday on CBS are are you learning
what it's like to be a member of a your
SEAL team I mean you are you well-versed
on all this well what's really good
about I mean so proud and of the work
we've done on two seasons with this show
I'm very humbled with Tier one operators
that we work with that are the real guys
that have done these missions in these
operations one guy in particular was 13
deployments he was one bin Laden raid
he was on captain Phillips I mean these
guys are producers on our show they're
not technical advisors there's writers
there's editors there's people on the
crew the cast that work on our show and
just to be around that in that energy as
we're telling these stories is a
blessing to play Jason Hayes who was a
leader of Bravo Team so for me it's a
humbling experience to show up every day
and work with these veterans and look at
the show more as a personal journey
outside of their their workplace because
it's a job what they do and then so
happens to be the most dangerous job in
the world
there's no retake you know you're there
make it protect you're gonna get killed
and they suffer from a lot of injuries
and they come back whether it's TBI or
PTSD and they're misunderstood or
they're not understood at all and last
week's episode we examine that with the
troubling aspect of you know these
veterans committing suicide and shooting
themselves from the heart
just pretty heavy and that has risen in
the past couple of months more and more
so so if we can tell stories like that
and set a light into that darkness then
that's really what the show is about and
we love the I love doing the show it's
very character-driven and I love playing
this guy and it's great to be around
these guys and give back so they're a
little bit there on the set they are at
you they are producers they are pumpkins
that are you know when we're doing a
mission or an operation and we're
breaching a door or we're doing a
situation where it is in a sticky
situation we talk about how they would
really do it and we break it down and
it's all in the dialogue is very real we
shoot it very fast on anamorphic lenses
so it's got that feeling of I would say
like ER emergency kind of a feel to it
it's very real it's a fast fast show to
watch and we're just you know gearing up
now and we just are finishing our season
two so excited about tonight and every
Wednesday 10:00 p.m. Eastern on CBS
before I let you go I want to play
celebrity true or false with David
Boreanaz let's go for it hit it with
celebrity true even it real celebrity
true or false with David Boreanaz first
up when you were a kid you were a ball
boy for the Steelers for three seasons
true or false that is correct that is
very true how the hell did that happen
we fortunately my older sister went to
school with one of the Rooneys when we
first moved to Philadelphia and they
became really close friends and then we
started to you know we became my parents
became friends with their parents and
the Rooneys and we just they're still
great friends of ours a great great
family organization and I was invited to
go work at Latrobe PA is a ball boy when
I was just almost 16 and I was 15 a time
and I was like working out with Jack
Lambert and catching balls from Mark
Malone
you know and then Stallworth was there
because he had retired and was just kind
of like the ushering of a bridge into a
new era of Steelers football so it was
pretty cool to be a part of that as your
dad was a weatherman yes you local
weatherman worked on on ABC for quite
some time but if you know for senda cuz
john facendo was a local anchor i mean
that they never do John Force and it was
a lot of voice of NFL Films okay yeah
yeah yeah well I was I was brought up by
cap city people because my father worked
for cap say okay I'm and I was kind of
like around that whole era of those guys
just took a shot on that one all right
next up you started a nail polish line
called chrome girl and this is aligned
with a set of NFL colors that a true
story that is a true story but it was
actually set up through my it was my
wife who actually got that going with a
partner and the NHL kind of colored line
was a branch to her line it was
something that was kind of an
enthusiastic about because I do a lot of
work with the NHL and charitable works
and with the Flyers of course sure
hockey is like my number one that's it
that's it I mean I mean I know we stuck
to eagles yeah I mean hockey and
football I mean I played football in
high school but hockey is like big for
me that's her okay so I assume that this
there's a blue line and the red line
dance
I just want to make sure last one for
you David Boreanaz true or false you
were featured in a music video of Dido's
2003 white flag all these truths man
this is very true yes okay how do we go
up with dynamite
you have no idea I do remember that
they're like looking at Mama's this
music video and I didn't know who Dido
was but they explained to me how great
it was watch you look like you're a guy
who was he had some place to go I don't
know I'm checking my watch now now those
things and okay she was very nice and
when I first met her I was just in the
Wardrobe experience and she was standing
there and I said I'm sorry I don't know
who Dido is okay she laughed and I'm
Dido okay was a little awkward moment
awkward I was kind of like the MacNab I
don't know she was a starter she was
definitely a starter she was a starter
so that's some quality No yeah early
aughts chill music a little deep I guess
a the rip the run rich run yes you do
I'm I'm so happy you're doing that
thanks man I love watching the combine I
watch it in my trailer when it goes on
and I'm not working and thank you I'd
love to come down in full seal gear and
possibly take you on that's like 80 to
120 pounds here's what I would love for
you to do at the very least is that next
year when video when you're in your yes
run of 40 on your set in your gear done
tweet it and put definitely put on your
Instagram yes well yes and throw it out
there and hashtag run rich Pierce be
part of the movement would love to
minused we'd love to do that no and I
would I would really I would really
really love to do we've we've raised a
nice chunk you have she gonna create you
out with that thanks brother yeah don't
wait for more years to come back here
okay I'd love coming back here it's a
great set I got great people and you got
a couple of Boston fan over there that I
haven't even really started I got a
Cowboys fan there who's you know well
we'll just leave it at that they didn't
have a good draft okay you got a
prediction for the year the Eagles you
know I think they're I think when so
it's got a lot to prove and like I said
chip-on-the-shoulder proves a lot and
I'm excited about their year and I think
I think they do make the playoffs and I
think they I think that the favorite for
me in the NFC East okay well I'm glad
you're departing now because the coach
of the Saints is about to call into the
show well
Kim I do like John page I feel bad for
Shawna what happened what happens in
replay that's that was bad well they
fixed it hopefully but it's good to see
I'm gonna take 20 minutes to make a call
let's hope not but we'll hold it down
will fine-tune it okay David underscore
Boreanaz on twitter and then join the
mass or massive following on instagram @
d Gbagbo 69 DB oh yeah okay he be like
Boreanaz bo r my son says dad what's up
with d bod i said son it's a cologne
line very good very good good to see ya
check out again SEAL team on CBS tonight
and every Wednesday 10:00 p.m. Eastern
Time on CBS for more of the Rich Eisen
show tune - audience Channel 239 on
DirecTV for free on BR Live or download
the Rich Eisen show app